t 2
堕ちそう堕ちそう
あやちょいではいおはようございます
これちょっとちょっとず道がは片道よーかんだねーむーん
はいおはようございます立つな寝起きの肇社長ですたいというわけで今日はですね1月
の6日のか今日は多分1月のメーカーがなのかなんですけど
今年ですね酉年なんでとしよっとこうなんです
けどもとすよとかつ実はアレなんですよとスーッとご活
厄年翻訳ですね厄年って言ってちょっとなことしねうん
体がすごいば類らしいんですよ打たれれば普通はねそのや形の人ってなんかちゃんとお
祓いとかに行かなきゃいけないらしいんですけど
お祓いがするような時間を知ったないみたいなので初詣だけはちゃんと言っておこうと
思いましてそう
月終わりぎわというか人が少なそうなタイミングを狙って一人で今からお前に行ってき
ますがまた大へと下がってくるでしょ
うわぁ軍でが寝不足ってわけじゃないけどよねーぞ
もうすぐ着きます多分とまずサークル9
よしを買いましょうはぁ
心臓してきたなぁ外で撮るの苦手なんすよこう見えてあなたお金もそうアー
人がいるなあああ
やばいやばいやばいやばいぶっ
てないな
想像の5倍は人がいます亜鉛うせんぼ移行するよ
ヒューというわけで登っていきます
あの何度も言うが
本当の
うーん着込まずの人見知りなので家で撮る時と人格が違います
気にしないでください
[音楽]
den
いいし
昨年ん
tv これは今から1月登っていきます
ああああああ
delorean
ni
ええええええ
[音楽]
中に入りましたこの奥に多分あれがあります
3倍というかお前でができるの場所もう少しだと思います頑張って要素
今日バレないなぁ
去痰ばれずに行けるぞこれ僕がきても誰ない気がするここは
つきましたたぶんこの日に喚く頭がある気がします
でああ
うん
こういう訳だん
お水物きゅっとしましたらいい
ちょっとって
人目が気になりますね家に帰りたい僕の今年の運勢はこうにかかっています
生きる気もするんですよサーキットみますではたのもなんか
大凶とかだけはやめてほしいはい
あれかなんですなんですよなんで年棒を
中吉です
あー中期津市
えっじゃあ交際抗議をしせず話をまとめは是非お水作業は良い
魚釣りしようかな末尾時長く待て音信がある願望一瞬に努力てよはい勝負事自重せよ
住居すぐ釣れこれ引っ越し雪がありますなぁと病気は治り器用に注意シェア
金融直結よろす分かった何かあったらすぐ買いますね
悪くはないんじゃないか2キチってたし結構まだいいほうだな気がするんで
去年は1年間お菓子を食べないと言う
ちょっと割と根がマンチックなことをしてたんですけど今年はちょっと一変して
いろいろやりたいことあったんですけどこれだけはやりたいっていうのを一つ決めたの
でそれだけちゃんと発表しようと思います
会え人多いなぁこの中で言うのか当初目標行けます
私はー
いやー我アジア堂前
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
バッハ
jr
あーエベッツ日られてるチーズめっちゃ見られるという